you can ride your bike 1/5 of a mile per
minute if it takes you 3 and 1/3 minutes
to get to your friends house how many
miles away does your friend live and
this here's pictures of these guys on
bicycles it's pretty clear they're not
riding to work or some of these guys
aren't even riding a bicycle but let's
focus on the question so you can ride
your bike 1/5 of a mile per minute and
you're going to do this for three and a
third minutes times three and a third so
we really have to figure out how do we
multiply 1/5 times 3 and 1/3 so there's
a couple of ways to think about it you
could literally view a 3 and a third as
this is the same thing as 1/5 times 3
times 3 plus 1/3 that's exactly what 3
and 1/3 is and then we can just apply
the distributive property this would be
1/5 times 3 1/5 times 3 I'm going to
keep the colors the same times 3 plus
1/5 plus 1/5 times 1/3 x times 1/3 and
this is going to be equal to well we
could rewrite 1/5 times 3 as 1/5 times 3
over 1
that's what 3 really is if we wrote it
as a fraction and then of course we're
going to have plus 1/5 1/5 times 1/3
times 1/3 and let's just think about
what each of these evaluate to here you
multiply the numerators and you multiply
the denominator so this is going to be
equal to 1 times 3 over 5 times 1 and
this business right over here is going
to be and remember order of operations
we want to do our multiplication first
so this is going to be 1 times 1 over 5
times 3 over 5 times 3 and so that's
going to be equal to 3 over 5 plus plus
1 over 15 and now we have different
denominators here but lucky for us 3
over 5 if we multiply the numerator and
the denominator by 3 we're going to get
it
later of 15 and so that's equal to 9
over 15 plus 1 over 15 which equals 10
over 15 and if you divide the numerator
and the denominator both by 5 you're
going to get 2 over 3 so your friend
lives 2/3 miles away from your house
well that's kind of interesting and this
tote was kind of a long way to do it
let's think about if there's a simpler
way to do it so this is the same thing
as 1/5 times and I'm just going to write
3 and 1/3 as a mixed number so it's 1/5
times 3 and 1/3 can be rewritten as 9/3
I'm sorry I'm going to rewrite 3 and 1/3
is an improper fraction so this is the
same thing as 9 thirds that's 3 plus 1/3
which is the same thing as 1/5 why
switch colors arbitrarily which is the
same thing same thing I'm still in the
same color as 1/5 times 1/5 times 9
thirds plus 1/3 is 10 thirds and now we
can just multiply the numerator and
multiply the denominator the numerator
or multiply the numerators so this is 1
times 10 1 times 10 I'm trying to stay
good with the color-coding over 5 times
3 over 5 times 3 which is exactly equal
to what we just got 1 times 10 is equal
to 10 5 times 3 is 15 10 15 so we
already established is the same thing as
2/3 so your friend lives 2/3 of a mile
away from you